we begin with new information about
president Trump's phone calls with
foreign leaders and it's putting the
spotlight on three of mr. Trump's
closest associates CBS News has learned
that Secretary of State Mike Pompeo was
listening to the president's phone call
with Ukraine's leader that triggered the
House impeachment inquiry so this
indicates at Pompeo new months ago that
the president wanted Ukraine to
investigate political rival Joe Biden
this comes as the president's personal
lawyer that's Rudy Giuliani was
subpoenaed by the house for his
involvement with Ukraine we also know
the president asked Australia's Prime
Minister to help find out how the Russia
investigation began and it was attorney
General William Barr who asked the
President to make that call Paula Reid
is at the White House Paula this is one
of those stories that just keeps getting
more significant what's today's
development mean good morning well Tony
the president's personal outreach to
Ukraine and Australia raises more
questions about whether the president
should be reaching out to foreign
leaders to help pursue investigations
into accusations that are largely
discredited about his political
opponents Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
left for Europe without addressing
questions about a July 25th call between
President Trump and his Ukrainian
counterpart that is now at the center of
an impeachment inquiry the secretary has
previously been evasive about how much
he knew about the president's
conversations what do you know about
those conversations so you just gave me
a report about a IC whistleblower
campaign not none of which I've seen the
House Foreign Affairs Committee
subpoenaed Pompeo last week demanding
that he turn over documents related to
the call I don't understand what he was
doing just sitting there watching as the
as the president was compromising our
national security
the president's July call isn't the only
conversation now under scrutiny CBS News
has learned Attorney General William
Barr asked President Trump to reach out
to the Prime Minister of Australia to
request help in the Justice Department's
review of the origins of the Russia
investigation in 2016 the Australian
Government alerted the FBI after
receiving information that rush
officials had contacted a member of the
Trump campaign how come it started it
was all nonsense who was a host the
president has long insisted the scrutiny
of his campaign was unlawful Barr spoke
to CBS News as Jan Crawford about why he
believed he needed to review the origins
of the Russia probe to ensure it was not
politically motivated that's one of that
you know one of the key functions of the
Attorney General core responsibilities
as Attorney General is to make sure that
government power is not abused the
president's personal attorneys who
defended him throughout the Muller
investigation are downplaying the
significance of this impeachment inquiry
they tell me they went through a real
war with Muller but they claimed this is
just a skirmish Anthony Paula Thanks